Since we're trying to find the roots of this equation, we need to set y equal to
0. Remember that the roots of the x-coordinates of the x-intercepts, which is
where y equals 0. Now, let's use the quadratic formula to solve this. Plugging
the proper coefficients into the proper spots in the quadratic formula, gives us
x equals negative 2 plus or minus the square root of 2 squared minus 4 times 1
times 10, all over 2. Let's simplify. Well, this is getting pretty interesting.
Look at what I have underneath my square root sign. We end up with negative 2
plus or minus the square root of negative 36 over 2. This is pretty shocking.
This problem is asking us to take the square root of a negative number. We can't
do that. We do not have any idea what real number this would equal. In fact,
there is no real number that this equals. So, what does this mean? No solutions?
No crossing in the x-axis? Well, we found a solution. Let's take a peek at the
graph. So, here's the graph of y equals x squared plus 2x plus 10. Remember,
when we were looking for roots, we're looking for the x-coordinates of
x-intercepts of the graph. But look at were our vertex is, it's right here way
above the x-axis and our parabola is point upward. Coming to the y-coordinate at
this point right here is the smallest y-coordinate of any point on this graph.
In other words, because this is the minimum point, the graph is never going to
get any closer to the x-axis, and so it's never going to touch it at all. This
is pretty fascinating. The weird thing is that we still got some sort of answer.
You'll have to wait for the next lesson though, to find out what this means.